-Hey, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't find him anywhere.
I wanted to get his advice
'cause I'm hosting "SNL"
this weekend
with Lizzo performing.
Who is this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Well, it's a-ready,
set, go, cat, go ♪
♪ I've seen things
that no one else knows ♪
♪ I'm Elvis ♪
♪ Elvis on the Shelvis ♪
♪ Well, I move around the house
when I'm a-home alone ♪
♪ You did what you did ♪
♪ You done what you done ♪
♪ Elvis on the Shelvis
never tell no one ♪
♪ I'm Elvis ♪
♪ Elvis on the Shelvis ♪
♪ Well, a-ho, ho, ho
and another ho ♪
♪ When it's time to go to bed,
don't you scream and shout ♪
♪ Taking care of business
what I'm really about ♪
♪ When you wake up,
you know where I'll be ♪
♪ Rockin' around
the Christmas tree ♪
♪ Before you go to bed,
make me cookies and milk ♪
♪ I'm 90% poly, 10% silk ♪
♪ I'm Elvis ♪
♪ Elvis on the Shelvis ♪
♪ Well, if you didn't know,
well, a-now you know ♪
♪ Well, I'm the Elvis ♪
♪ Well, on the Shelvis ♪
♪ I'm watching youuuuu ♪
♪♪
Merry Christmas, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right, baby. Come on.
-You're going on
the top of my tree.
[ Cheers and applause ]